If being alive on earth was some kind of contest,
humans, I think, would win it hands down.
As a population of organisms, we're the Michael
Phelps of being alive,
only we have like 250,000 times more gold
medals.
Last week, we talked about exponential growth,
when a population grows at a rate proportional
to the size of the population, even as that
size of that population keeps increasing.
Well, since around the year 1650, the human
population has been undergoing probably the
longest period of exponential growth of any
large animal in history ever.
In 1650, there were about 500 million people
on the planet.
By 1850, the population had doubled to 1 billion.
And it doubled again just 80 years after that,
and doubled again just 45 years after that.
We are now well past 7 billion and counting.
So think about this:
today, there are 80 year olds who have watched the population of their species on earth triple.
So why is this happening? And how? And how
long can it go on, because it's kind of uncomfortable?
[Theme Music]
Let's say you're shopping for dinner, and bear with me, we're going to relate it back to ecology in a second,
but you've got a lot of choices at your grocery store, you could buy five packs of ramen for a dollar,
or you could buy some fancy ravioli made by Italian nuns out of organic pasta for like $20 a pound.
They're both noodles, they're both food, but
you know, with the ramen, you get more,
whereas with the handmade stuff, it tastes
better -- higher quality. What do you do?
It's a perennial problem in nature, and in
our lives, satisfying the two competing impulses:
Do I have more or do I have the best? Quantity
or quality? Tough choice.
Although we're not really aware of it, all organisms make a similar choice through how they reproduce.
In ecology, we size up who chooses quantity over quality by something called the R vs. K Selection Theory.
The R vs. K Selection Theory says that some organisms will reproduce in a way that aims for huge exponential growth,
while others are just content to hit the number
of individuals that their habitat can support,
that is, the carrying capacity, and then stay
around that level.
Species that reproduce in a way that leads
to very fast growth are called R-Selected Species
because R is the maximum growth rate of a population when you're talking math-talk, as we learned last week.
The very-strongly R selected animals make a lot of babies in their lifetime and just hope that they make it.
If some of the babies get eaten or something,
no biggie, there are others where those came from.
On the other hand, K-selected species only make a few babies in their lifetime and they invest in them very heavily.
K in math language is carrying capacity, since
K-selected species usually end up living at
population densities closer to their carrying
capacity than R-selected ones.
Of course, things aren't so cut and dry in nature as most animals aren't very strongly K-selected or R-selected.
It's actually, you know, a spectrum.
Some organisms, usually small-ish ones, reproducing more on the R side,
and others, usually larger ones, on the K
side. Most species are somewhere in the middle.
So the reason I'm telling you this is to drive
home how bananas it is that humans have gotten
to the population size we have.
Because we tend to reproduce way on the K-selected
side of the spectrum,
we're pretty big mammals, usually only have
a few kids during our lifetimes,
and those kids are a total pain in the butt to raise, but we put a ton of resources into them anyways.
So even though humans reproduce K-selected-ishly,
for the past few centuries,
our population growth curve has been looking
suspiciously like that of an R-selected species.
And exponential growth, even for R-selected
species, usually does not go on for 350 years.
Well, how did this all happen?
Well, the short answer is that humans figured out how to raise our carrying capacity so far indefinitely,
and we did this by eliminating a bunch of
obstacles that would have made our numbers
level off at a carrying capacity a long, long
time ago.
These obstacles you will recall are limiting factors, and we managed to blast them to pieces in a few different ways.
First, we've upped our ability to feed ourselves.
Our crazy rapid population growth started
in Europe around the 17th century because
that's when agriculture was becoming mechanized.
And fancy new farming practices like the domestication
of animals and crops were increasing food production.
From Europe, those agricultural practices
and their accompanying population explosion
spread to the New World and to much of the rest of the world by the mid-19th century.
Another game changer for the human population
came in the form of medical advances.
Anton van Leeuwenhoek, father of microbiology,
all around really smart guy,
was the first modern scientist to propose
the germ theory of disease in 1700,
and even though it took about a century and
a half for people to take it seriously,
it revolutionized human health, leading to
things like vaccinations.
Suddenly, people stopped dying of stupid, avoidable stuff as they had been for thousands of years,
which meant that everybody lived longer, childhood
survival rates improved,
and those kids went on to make their own babies
and get very, very old.
And we also increased our carrying capacity
by not being so disgusting.
We figured that you can't just sit around
in your own poop and live to tell the tale,
so sewage systems became a thing.
In Europe, at least, it started around the 1500s, but they weren't widely used until the 1800s,
and we all benefited from that.
And, finally, we've gotten a lot better at
living comfortably in inhospitable places.
That is to say, people have been living in
deserts and tundra for thousands of years,
but in the 20th century we expanded the human
habitat to pretty much everywhere in the world,
thanks to heating and air conditioning and
warm clothes and airplanes
and trucks that bring food everywhere from
Svalbard, Norway to New South Wales.
So for all those reasons and more, humans have been able to avoid that old party pooper carrying capacity,
which is good, 'cause I don't like it when
people die, it's just, it's just a downer.
And a lot of smart scientists and mathematicians
and economists have argued that each person
born in the past 350 years has not only represented
another mouth to feed, but also two hands
to work to raise the human carrying capacity,
just enough for themselves and a teensy bit more.
So then as our population grows, our carrying
capacity grows right along with it,
like some really steep escalator going up
and the ceiling just above our heads,
and if it stayed there, we'd all get squished
but it keeps moving.
But of course, this can't go on forever.
The human population does have a carrying
capacity, it's just that nobody's sure what it is.
Back in 1679, it was Leeuwenhoek himself who
was the first to publicly hazard a guess about
the Earth's carrying capacity for humans,
guessing it to be around 13.4 billion people.
Since then, estimates have ranged from 1 billion
to 1 trillion, which is one thousand billion,
so that seems a little extreme, but the averages
of these estimates are from 10-15 billion folks.
And we need a lot of obvious things to survive
-- food, clean water, non-renewable resources
like metals and fossil fuels --
but everything that we consume requires space,
whether it's space to grow or space to mine
or produce or put our waste.
So a lot of ecologists make their estimates
of how many people this planet can handle
based on an ecological footprint,
a calculation of how much land and how many resources each person on the planet requires to live.
That footprint is very different depending
on where you live and what your habits are.
People in India use a lot fewer resources
and therefore, space, than Americans for example.
Meat eaters require a lot more acreage than
vegetarians;
in fact, if everybody on the planet ate as much meat as the wealthiest people in the world do,
current food harvests could feed less than
half of the present world's population.
So despite the fact that the earth is a very
big place, space is a real limiting factor for us,
and as our population grows, there will probably
be more conflict over how our space is used.
For instance, if there really were a trillion people on the planet, everybody would have to live, grow food on,
and poop on, a 12-by-12 meter patch of ground,
about half the size of a tennis court.
So it could be that you could fit a thousand
billion people on earth,
but I can guarantee that those people would
have a hard time getting along with each other.
But how about we stop thinking about ourselves
just for a moment?
As we take up more space, we also leave less
space for other species,
and as we use resources like trees and soil
and clean water,
that reduces the amount available to all kinds
of other organisms.
This is why biologists say that we are currently
living through one of the biggest extinction
events in recent geological history.
We're outcompeting other species for the very
basics of life.
And eventually, or in the case of oil and water, already, we're starting to compete with ourselves as a species.
So serious stuff here, but here's a little
glimmer of hope:
unlike some other animals, a lot of our actions
are based on a little thing called culture,
and human culture has brought about some huge
changes in the last 50 years.
The fact is, even though the human population
continues to grow,
the rate of population growth actually peaked
around 1962 and has been declining every since.
At its peak, the human population was growing
at about 2.2% per year,
and these days, it's declined to about 1.1%
and it's still falling.
Families in most industrialized countries
are getting smaller and smaller, but why?
Well, part of that has to do with women.
As women in developed nations get more education,
they're having babies later in life,
and when an animal doesn't reproduce to its
fullest potential --
meaning it doesn't start having babies as
soon as it's like, sexually able to --
that animal is going to have fewer offspring.
Also, if you get women more choices and more
education,
they might be more liable to choose a second career in astrophysics rather than becoming a mother.
Another reason for the falling population growth rate has to do with the way that we live our lives.
Back in the early 20th century, more of the world worked on farms, and maybe ate their own food.
Kids were a real asset to a farm back then;
it's a good example of that idea about more
hands doing more work to increase the carrying
capacity of the human population.
Yeah, kids were an extra mouth to feed,
but they were also a really important work force and you could just feed the kids the stuff you were producing.
That's what we call a positive feedback loop;
as the population grows, the workforce gets bigger and the place, as a result, supports more of us.
But these days, that's not happening so much
anymore.
More and more people are living in cities where you don't need kids to help with the crops,
so fewer people are having them, because:
a.) they cost a lot of money to raise,
b.) they're not bringing in money like they
were back on the farm,
and c.) a lot of people have access to good birth control, so they don't have as many "oops"-children.
All these factors together are forming a negative
feedback loop,
the effects of reproduction in this case work
to slow down the rate of reproduction.
But just because our population's growth rate
is decreasing doesn't mean that this juggernaut
of humanity is going to stop anytime soon.
In addition to reminding us that the rules of ecology apply to us just like any other organism,
human population is important to think about because we kind of need to do something about it.
And I think pretty much every other species
on the planet would agree with me on that.
Thanks for watching this episode of Crash
Course: Ecology,
and thanks to all the people who helped us
put it together.
If you want to review anything from this episode,
there's a table of contents over there,
and if you have any questions or ideas or
comments, we're on Facebook and Twitter and
of course, down in the comments below.
We'll see you next time.